reckless in Vegas wants you to ante up
and give back joining us now is band
founder Michael Shapiro and Lance knight
from Saint Jude's Ranch for children to
tell us more about this Michael and
Lance thank you both for joining us
Michael you started Andy up tell us what
it's all about I did I as much as I
loved I have a lot of passion for music
it's also about giving back to
non-profits and and I came across the
interviews around for children uh 2015
and I've just made it kind of my
advocacy to try to get back to them so
while I'm on stage performing doing what
I love I know that money is going to
charity every time and that you can't
get better so great and such a great
cause Lance for those who are not
familiar for with St Jude's Ranch for
children which has been around for more
than 50 years tell us more about that
yeah you bet for 56 years now St Jude
transfer children has been a community
of Hope and healing for children that
are and youth that are have been abused
and neglected donations such as
Michael's support thanks Michael really
appreciate it make a huge impact on
these kids lives I would say that our
organization relies on the generosity of
the community to help us
create hope healing
provide shelter behavioral health
transitional housing yeah it just makes
such a difference in the lives of these
children who have already gone through a
lot and tell us about the groundbreaking
really briefly that just took place
which is so exciting so we are going to
build The Healing Center for the
prevention of child sex trafficking it's
a real problem in our community it's a
real problem all across the United
States this is the first of its kind in
the U.S this will be a facility to house
at any time girls that have been taken
in from the streets and and pulled away
from those bad people and we're going to
break that cycle of abuse and neglect
love it Michael where and you have such
a passion for this and and it is so
appreciated where can people get tickets
for this and and how do they learn more
at Sahara Las Vegas in the Sahara
theater on Thursdays and Fridays it's an
8 30 show you can go to Ticketmaster can
go to recklessvegas.com we'll be there
every Thursday and Friday till the end
of the year we have special guests and
we also every month we get a sponsor
this month Mercado interior interiors
and attorney Stephen scal is given Stu's
Ranch 65 thank you
both for being here and before we take
off uh Michael if you could just give us
a sample of what people can look forward
to
dream
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whenever I want you all I have to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if that is why whatever
his dream
yes yes
thank you so much top that Rocky